as you'll see uh if you do watch it on
youtube
kiara is uh is a star
and she studies stars that are
exceptionally interesting or dead stars
or
corpses stellar corpses i don't know uh
in any case let me just check to see if
we're live and assuming that we
are we can start this phenomenal
discussion i've waited years to have
with kiara because i've been a big fan
of her work
even tried to get her to come to ucsd
but we won't talk about that um
those are painful experiences for me but
she's uh
truly an exceptional scientist a good
friend
of many of my uh colleagues and and
myself in the field
i'm going to play in the background
let's see if this will work this would
be cool if it works
uh share screen open kiara can you hear
me
hello kiara oh she's in the green room
hold on one second everybody getting
this all cued up in real time this is
real time
science and now it's asking me for
passwords
see if that will work nope cancel
sorry all right um
jess is in the green room kr can you
hear me
yes i can hear you now okay good all
right
some reason it was putting it in
i want to go back to camera mode there
we are
hi kiara hi hi
sorry about that it's always fun to do
live streaming
oh they're actually doing it they're
actually showing it oh no that's your
video
so there's an amazing amazing video that
nanograv has put out
uh featuring our own guest kiara
mingerelli
am i saying that right i'm always
confused it's the heart g
mingorelli vingarelli it's good to see
you it's good to be with you thanks for
joining me into the impossible podcast
yeah thank you for inviting me so i've
of course followed your career for many
years and been
fascinated by the stuff that you do i
first want to say to everyone who's
listening at clubhouse you can watch the
fun
on youtube dr brian keating
we are streaming from there and if we
have time we'll take some questions
we're on a little bit of a tight
time schedule today but that shouldn't
deter you from
asking any burning questions i'll
certainly have time to take maybe one or
two
but today we are going to talk about
this interesting discovery
uh that has huge implications and a
little bit of frustration for me kiara
because as you know
i build a gravitational wave detector
that's a huge
uh you know telescopes and and so forth
that detect the signal
via the cosmic microwave background we
hope and here you are outdoing me
building a galaxy sized detector of
gravitational waves
uh first of all go home
that's right so can you introduce
yourself
uh who you are where you are how you
spend your time
on planet earth and uh and tell us about
the lovely university of connecticut
which is i was mentioning is where the
alma mater
of my beloved mother barbara keating so
kiara tell us who you are
who am i i'm a gravitational wave
astrophysicist
i'm originally from ottawa canada and
i've done my studies all over the planet
so i did my undergraduate degree in
canada and then graduate work
in italy and then the uk
then i lived in california for a while
and then germany then new york and now
i'm an assistant professor
here at the university of connecticut
and you have another
kind of part-time job or maybe sometimes
his full-time job
and that's as a as a research
fellow or scientist at the flatiron
institute at the center for
computational astrophysics
in new york city which is a project of
the simon's foundation tell us about
that
and what do you do there so
at the center for computational
astrophysics or cca
as you said i'm an associate research
scientist so i think about
how supermassive black holes merge and
all the different ways that they can
merge
and emit gravitational waves as they're
merging and then
try to figure out how all of this
happens
using these super computing facilities
there that are really one of a kind
so it's a huge resource and benefit to
my research to to work there
um i also am really plugged into the new
york community there
so not only is cca a wonderful place and
of itself but it also hosts
really big communities so we have
colleagues at cuny columbia nyu
rutgers princeton um it's a real nexus
of people coming in and up or at least
it used to be
those are my last memories there which
were almost a year ago at this point
uh right now we're all working remotely
but hopefully we can go back soon
yeah that's right the the city has
become a
very different version of what it used
to be but i have many many
fond memories of uh seeing you work in
your cubicle along with all my friends
at the cca
it's really a fantastic organization and
really unlike any other organization of
its kind
uh to my knowledge so it's very uh it's
very impressive how
uh how far it's come in such a short
period of time and and how it continues
to grow
uh so i particularly as you as i said
earlier i want to talk to you for a
while
uh maybe over a year and then i was like
well this
announcement that was made just about a
month ago really
set the astronomical community abuzz and
i felt like
it would be wonderful to have you on the
into the impossible podcast
to tell us a little bit first of all
starting from the very basics
what is a pulsar why are they
interesting how do you build a
gravitational wave detector
from a network of pulsars and then what
the discovery that you guys
announced back at the double as meeting
is all about so first of all what is a
pulsar
why should we care how does it affect
joe beggar don't no no i'm not going to
say that i hate when they ask me that
question
um yeah don't dumb it down but please
yeah what is a pulsar why are they so
fascinating to you
sure so uh a pulsar is a neutron star
and a neutron star is a dead core
of a star that was about 10 to 25 times
the mass of the sun
so when the star dies it goes supernova
and what's left over is this neutron
star in the center
so there's so much pressure during this
implosion
during the supernova implosion explosion
event
that the protons and the electrons get
squished together to make this ball of
neutrons
now there's not enough mass for it to
continue to collapse into a black hole
but there's enough so that about 1.4
times the mass of the sun
is squeezed into a space that has the
diameter
of the island of manhattan for example
so
something that's the size of manhattan
has 1.4 times the mass of the sun in it
and
spins around hundreds of times per
second
those are the objects that we use as
gravitational wave detectors
so the way that we can do that is
because the spin axis of the pulsar
is misaligned with its magnetic field
line so if it's this is the spin axis
and then the magnetic field line is this
way then every time it spins around it
sends a flash of radio waves towards the
earth
and each one of these flashes is very
regular so we know
exactly when the flashes should arrive
at the earth
and of course we measure when they do
arrive at the earth
and the difference between when we
expect the signal to arrive
and when it actually arrives could
signal the presence of
gravitational waves now that's because
gravitational waves change the distance
between the earth
and the pulsar and so gravitational
waves stretch and squash the fabric of
space-time right in this kind of plus
fashion or in a cross fashion
there's more if you believe other
theories of gravity or extensions to gr
um we can probably talk about that later
yeah so
the the important part though is this
this time advance
or delay depending on if you're being
compressed
or uh or stretched out and that's what
we can find using these ultra stable
millisecond pulsars
and so how did the idea of nano grab how
did that come to be
what was sort of the impetus for it and
how is it designed quote unquote
um to do what it's uh what it's doing
well the history of nanograv and of
pulsar timing really goes all the way
back
to i mean
to the discovery of pulsars in 1967 by
jocelyn bell and and her collaborators
um she was one of the first people to
discover pulsars and then millisecond
pulsars which are the ultra stable
version of these were discovered in 1982
so in fact not that long ago
the idea though of using a regular
signal and changing and trying to change
differences in the arrival time in the
signal goes back to 1975
uh when some scientists said jpl
proposed to do this with the pioneer 10
spacecraft
and that was an amazing idea they were
the ones that proposed like oh you know
what this spacecraft is going really far
away and
and actually if we can detect changes in
the arrival times of the signals from
the spacecraft
then we might be able to look for
gravitational waves
and so by using these ultra stable
millisecond pulsars together with this
idea of um
of changing arrival times we can come
together with this idea of pulse our
timing arrays but i mean it really took
a lot of people a lot of time to get the
idea off the ground
the the work that i think is the
the that forms the basis of our current
collaboration
um is the 1983 paper by hellings and
downs who really had the idea of
cross-correlating all of these
millisecond pulsars to look for
a gravitational wave signal that's
common in all of them
so nanograv in itself started about
13 years ago and the idea of pulsar
timing rays of course is is much much
older than that so nanograv is only one
of the pulsar timing arrays that exists
around the earth
there's also the park's pulsar timing
array in australia and the european
pulsar timing array
and there's some emerging pulsar timing
arrays now the indian pulsar timing
array south african pulsar timing array
chinese pulsar timing array
and so together we share data and are
forming the international pulsar timing
array oh wow
now the results that you announced uh
last
month at the american astronomical
societies meeting
uh those were acquired recently are they
from a decade ago i
remembered something like 12 and a half
years plus more years so
can you clarify how much data was
actually obtained to make this
announcement
and then where where does the future see
us going in this particular
direction yes so
at the american astronomical society
meeting uh
we announced that we discovered the
first hint of a gravitational wave
background so this took 12 and a half
years
of data and that means hundreds of
people have been
timing these millisecond pulsars in this
instance there were 45 millisecond
pulsars that we used
and their uh length span from three
years to the full twelve and a half
years which means you know people have
been going back to these pulsars roughly
every two weeks
for 12 and a half years to time them to
look for gravitational wave signals
uh so i'm not sure you can you can be
too upset with us
brian for you know having a hint of a
signal after 12 and a half years of
doing this experiment you know and
timing every two weeks
right now my uh my uh soon-to-be
five-year-old
always wants to give me a hint of what
i'm gonna get her for her birthday
what does it mean uh a hint what does
that mean
is that like a skosh or a little t
tidbit
how do we quantify what a hint means and
why do you use a particular claim
rather than saying detection or evidence
right so detection and evidence for are
very technical words that have very
strong meaning in the scientific
community and we're not
that confident yet uh and so
what we found in the 12 and a half year
data is a signal that's
present in all 45 of the millisecond
pulsars and that signal
has the same amplitude in all of these
45 millisecond pulsars
now we've tried to figure out if
something else could be generating this
signal and so far we've come up short so
we can't think of anything else that
could be generating the signal but that
doesn't mean
that there isn't something else so what
we expect when we do eventually make the
detection
is that there are two parts to the
detection story
the first is seeing this common
amplitude this this common
uh low frequency signal in all the
pulsars
now these millisecond pulsars are
scattered about in our own galaxy
and they're thousands of light years
away from the earth and from each other
so having a signal that's present in all
of these pulsars at the same time
is really exceptional right and one of
the only physical processes that could
be generating that
would be this gravitational wave
background and we believe that this
comes from the cosmic merger history
of supermassive black holes so
the first step is this common amplitude
now the second step
is looking for this uh signal that you
get when you cross
correlate all of the millisecond pulsars
now according to
einstein's theory of general relativity
there
is a quadrupolar type shape so it kind
of
you start up and it goes down like a
cosine but it doesn't quite come up
again
to the same level that it started so
there's this distinctive shape and we
call it the hellings and downs curve
and when we cross correlate all of these
millisecond pulsars we expect this shape
to emerge from the data
these spatial correlations so if two
pulsars are nearby to each other they'll
be positively correlated and that means
that if they move
they move like this at the same time
now if they're negatively correlated or
anti-correlated like two paul separated
by
a hundred degrees on the sky then they
would move like this
with respect to each other so they'd be
anti-correlated
and so this tellings and downs curve
tells us how
all of these different pulsar pairs
should be correlated if they're under
the influence
of a gravitational wave background we
have not
seen that part of the signal yet so
we've seen
part of it what we believe to be part of
it
but the second part is what we
definitely need in order to have a
smoking gun
kind of detection of the gravitational
wave background
now for anyone who's studied statistics
on the call
or has ever placed a bet at a roulette
table
uh right now we believe that the
evidence for there being
some common signal in the pulsars and
it's not just some intrinsic noise in
the pulsars that the odds of that
are about ten thousand to one so i'm
definitely putting my money on that
right um but the odds of that
common signal also having these spatial
correlations that we
expect from a gravitational wave
background right now is about
three or four to one so good odds but
not really convincing enough to have a
press conference
and you know say that we've made the
ultimate detection
of a gravitational wave background so we
think that we're getting close because
we've seen part of the signal
but we need about two and a half or
three years more data
in order to really be sure in order to
see those spatial correlations that are
emerging that are predicted by
general relativity oh very good um so
just reminder to folks that are
listening on clubhouse we're also
live streaming and recording to youtube
you can catch that there with some
uh more information about kiara and we
are for those of you on youtube they
might want to ask a question with your
verbal abilities i will take questions
in just a bit i do have a question on
you
on youtube from one of my listeners
american magna
he is or she is asking how has the
signal changed at all
even by the same amount in the last 12
years has there been
noticeable variation or time variability
or has it been relatively consistent
over the last decade plus
what a great question so the signal
itself has a different amplitude
at different frequencies right and we
call that a spectrum
and we haven't been able to get our
detector
down to the level where that signal
exists until now
where we've discovered part of the
signal this correlated amplitude but not
yet the spatial correlations
and so it's this um interplay between
what's generated in nature right this
gravitational wave background that comes
from
potentially the cosmic merger history of
supermassive black holes
and our ability to get enough pulsars
that are sensitive enough to bring our
instrument
you know down to a sensitivity where we
can detect that signal
so um i think i'm going to take another
question those of you on clubhouse
feels uh please feel free to raise your
hand
i'm happy to take you up on stage while
i am
also asking all my questions of my
friend kiara there's another question of
uh can you reveal more
about the properties of these mergers
you know someone's asking could you see
uh hawking radiation are there are there
other features
in in kind of the black hole or merger
history that would um
maybe have some uh impact on our
understanding of gr
or perhaps of our understanding of at
least the statistical behavior of these
objects
learning more about the intrinsic their
intrinsic properties rather than
them as a collective brian you have a
very intelligent audience this is a
fantastic
question well they rise to the
occasional question i didn't plant this
question
no it's not though it's another
mingorelli i don't know it must be some
other you know just it's just a
coincidence no
i'm just kidding good girl i was gonna
say is it my dad
that's my dad okay
um right so so absolutely yes
now i was telling you a little bit
earlier that you have
this amplitude of the gravitational wave
background that's a function of its
frequency
right so it should be some sort of uh
you know
tilted line like this right we call it a
power law
it really just means that the amplitude
scales like the frequency to the minus
two-thirds
now that's true if black holes are
circular when they're emitting these
gravitational waves and that nothing
else is interacting with them
however we know that supermassive black
holes in these binary
systems are in the centers of galaxies
and they're surrounded by gas
and dust and and stars
so if stars cross the orbit of the
binary and are slingshot out that's
going to take away some energy
from the binary and that energy is not
gravitational wave so in fact it changes
the separation of the binary in a
different way than gravitational waves
do
so if stars are the dominant way that
the supermassive black holes are merging
at very low frequencies or very wide
binary separations
that'll change the shape of this strain
spectrum
that that's what we call it but it's
really just this kind of behavior
that we think should be a straight line
and makes it turn over at very
low frequencies similarly if your
black holes have an accretion disk
around
both black holes we call it a circum
binary disk but it just means that
there's
an accretion disk around both black
holes they're in the middle that can
torque the binary and that also takes
away energy and angular momentum from
your system
and causes the black holes to merge more
quickly than just gravitational waves
alone
so both of these processes can leave
imprints
and what we measure when we measure the
gravitational wave background amplitude
as a function of frequency
very nice so next we're going to take a
question from the audience at clubhouse
and we have eric and miguel uh yeti
tears aka
um yeti tears miguel tully and first we
have eric eric
do you have a comment question or topic
for kiara
just have one question how do you
uh confirm that um dark matter isn't uh
responsible for some of the effects and
delays that you're seeing
that's a great question so dark matter
wouldn't have the same uh
structure that we see when we cross
correlate the pulsar so i was talking a
little bit earlier about this
quadripolar type shape we expect to see
when we're cross-correlating the
millisecond pulsars dark matter wouldn't
create that distinctive shape however
you'd be correct in thinking that you
know dark matter
has a gravitational field and as a
pulsar pulse traverses the galaxy
um that could cause a timing delay right
from that one pulsar on its way to the
earth
that's absolutely right but that time
delay would not be the same
uh and all of the millisecond pulsars
are timing and it wouldn't have that
spatial structure
that uh einstein tells us should be
there
so for an individual pulsar absolutely
that's a really interesting way
of trying to map the milky way and its
gravitational potential
it's a really interesting idea um but
we're we're sure that what we're seeing
right now is not due to dark matter
because
um it doesn't have that well because
dark matter wouldn't have that
quadripolar type shape and it would be
different
for all of the pulsars in the array
depending on
what the local structure would look like
oh very good
uh thank you thank you eric um great
question
yeah very we have the brightest minds in
the multiverse and
the only thing i pride myself on kiara
is that i give
um i invented clubhouse streaming for
scientific podcasts
interactivity as well as taking it live
i mean there's lots of great people that
do wonderful
conversations with folks all over the
internet especially in science i'm not
the only one but
but i love the fact that my audience can
interact with my guest you know because
how often is it you get somebody
as great as you in fact kiara you'll be
interested to know
that someone by the name of michael p
says
the following uncontroversial statement
kiara is awesome smiley emoji with
sunglasses kiara you should be
so thrilled i hope you can feel that i
don't know who michael p is michael
these sunglasses here i have my regular
glasses
that's right you must be a nerd uh like
me uh
carol here's your professor physics
professor that's right it's just
just like just like i aspire to be
someday
okay uh ibrahim ibrahim is asking a
question about the computational
requirements this is a cool question i
was interested too
what kinds of computation why are you
using the cca the full power of the cca
or are you using it
what kind of computing power if i want
to do it at home on my uh
on my motorola flip phone can i do it
your motorola flip phone oh my goodness
i don't think that your motorola flip
phone could do it maybe if you had a
blackberry back in the day
oh you canadian you exactly right
go rim so uh let's see
computing resources so i use computing
resources differently
like in my own personal research than
what we use for
these big gravitational wave background
searches and that's also different from
what other people at cca use the
computers for so in my personal research
what i try to do is create a hundred
thousand versions
of the local universe and try to figure
out the statistics of which local
galaxies can host supermassive black
hole binary systems for example
so my computations are what we call
embarrassingly parallelizable
so you know one realization might take
five minutes
um but if i have ten thousand cores
everything can take five minutes
right it just depends on how many times
i can run
this uh simulation over and over and
over again to get this
large number of statistics now with the
uh nanograph calculations of the
gravitational wave background and i
should say this paper was led by a
postdoc called joe simon
there you have these large markov chain
monte carlo
analyses that are taking place and not
only do you have 45 millisecond pulsars
that you need to
solve for their intrinsic red noise for
example
but they have lots of underlying
parameters each pulsar has
almost 10 different parameters in itself
to solve
for and the amplitude of the
gravitational wave background
and the frequency dependence that i was
telling you about that goes like
frequency to the minus two-thirds for
supermassive black holes
but you can leave that minus two-thirds
as a dependence to solve for
to say well what if i'm completely
agnostic right what if it's not minus
two-thirds what if it's something else
i'm gonna also solve for that parameter
uh so you have these huge mcmc
chains that can take weeks to even
longer potentially longer to converge
on an answer so that's how we use
supercomputers in that sense
and at cca i have some colleagues who
work on large cosmological simulations
like illustrious eagle
simba and those just basically take as
much
computing resources as you have right
that just kind of
just spreads out and takes everything
that you
possibly have available so i like to
tell my students that for us
you know our work is going to take you
know for three three to four weeks per
year for my
personal research that i lead i'm gonna
saturate all of the cca computers and
then we analyze that data
for the rest of the year and then we
come back so that's good to have we have
a nice mix of people who use the
resources in different ways and that way
everyone gets along right and no no
computing resource is wasted
question from jose could you detect
longitudinal gravitational waves in the
background if they exist absolutely so
these would be extensions to general
relativity and they would have different
correlation structures
so um you're clearly an expert
so i i'll tell you a little bit more
information
so general relativity have these plus
and cross
polarizations right which means that's
how gravitational waves can change the
fabric of space time
you can also have breathing modes right
in these extensions to gr
so you have plus and cross and breathing
mode you can also have
in other theories gravitational waves
that extend space-time along the way
that it's traveling and that would
create something that doesn't look like
a typical
quadrupole or hellings and downs curve
so uh
sydney chamberlain kj lee
javier siemens have all studied these
results and
and can show you exactly what these
different correlation curves look like
very good and we're getting towards the
end we have about eight minutes left uh
before i have to break off into one of
my
telecons you know kr i thought as an
astronomer i'd be on telescopes all the
time
i'm just on telecons all the time it's
very frustrating
uh i know you can surprise with that
uh so where do we go from here when uh
when i looked at this
uh emmy-worthy or oscar-worthy video
that yukon
huskies put out uh last month this is
just so spectacular
it's on kiara's website uh and you guys
should watch it on youtube
but the uh the implications we might be
able to discuss
the or detect with nanograv you might be
able to detect the
primordial gravitationally background
now you're in front
of then we would have beef right yeah
that's right now you're infringing on my
i don't care canadian or not that is a
shot across my body um so charlie would
not be sorry if we detected a primordial
gravitational wave
just to be clear i would not either i
would not either let a thousand
pulsars in cmb modes bloom uh can you
tell me though how would that work and
how would you distinguish it
from the uh from the merger black uh
background that you
may have indeed detected right so this
um
[Music]
the way that the amplitude of the
background changes as a function of
frequency can tell you what's sourcing
or generating the gravitational wave
background so
a primordial gravitational wave
background say
these you know quantum fluctuations in
the early universe that are then
uh through inflation um you know the
whole size
of the universe can induce gravitational
waves that we can detect
that has a different spectral dependence
so instead of going like
uh frequency to the minus two-thirds a
primordial background should go like
frequency to the minus one
and for the experts that's what it's
flat in omega gw's like we like we
expect
um but you could have other kinds of
cosmologies if you believe in bouncing
universes equarosis
or string gas cosmologies other kinds of
exotic physics
um then you can have something called
the blue tensor index and you could
potentially detect a signal
that is visible in the pulsar timing
array part of the spectrum
and not necessarily visible in or could
still be hidden in terms of
a little ligo gravitational wave
background so instead of having
something that's flat it could tilt up
and um and be blue in that sense so if
things
tilt up they're called blue if they're
tilt down they're called red
but yeah you could have these uh blue
tensor indices so it could be really
interesting too yeah
but this is far from standard cosmology
as you know
so there is a question by ivan on
youtube that asks a question that's kind
of painful for me to
suggest but as you know there have been
claims of detections of the primordial
gravitational wave background
that were later found to be contaminated
by dust
um i happen to know a little bit about
that uh yes
yes kiara it's true uh but that was in
the introduction to my phd thesis
by the way i was so excited i wrote like
a whole section on bicep too
i was like this is so cool we have to
reach you have to retract your phd then
kr i'm sorry to tell you no
um the phd police will come and take it
away from me
ivan is asking could there be any local
change in the ism
maybe the um dispersion measure
something like could that
explain the signal is that a big
systematic
it's a big systematic and it's something
that we think about a lot in fact in
nanograph there's an interstellar media
mitigation group all they do is think
about this
so the interstellar medium could indeed
be a correlated
signal between all of the pulsars or
many pulsars in a particular line of
cider just depending on if there's like
a blob
of something that's affecting multiple
pulsar lines of sight
it doesn't have the quadrupolar type
shape
right but it couldn't do some sort of
common time delay
and so something like that um you know
we can't rule out at the moment
even though we think that that's really
unlikely uh and so again we're not
claiming a detection until we can find
um this quadripolar type correlation
that we call the hellings and downs
curve
but yes it's uh it's a galactic scale
gravitational wave detector
we can't turn off the pulsars and turn
them on again and see if they behave
differently
we don't have a nice vacuum cylinder
that goes all the way to the pulsar to
make sure that there's no
gas and dust along the way so we can
learn a lot about the interstellar
medium
um but as you're very bright
listener points out it can it can also
be a pain
yeah so last question from youtube i'll
take one from
uh clubhouse one more from youtube and
then we have to break off actually
then i have one question as the host of
the into the impossible podcast
so find us on youtube if you're on
youtube give it a thumbs up give me a
subscribe
uh tell me what you learned from this
episode and hopefully we'll get kiara
back if we get enough
groundswell i promised her i wouldn't
tell her how many hundreds of people are
watching her right now
okay uh last question from ibrahim on uh
on youtube is also very interesting
could you tell anything about the effort
to map the milky way's gravitational
field
and whether or not nanogravis is
participating in that effort
to map out presumably influence of dark
matter and other features in our
galactic gravitational potential
it's a really interesting interesting
and exciting project right now it's not
one of the key nanograph projects
although
there are a few scientists who are
involved in doing that but these are
more
of our our pet projects right now not
one of the flagship
uh results that we're really putting a
lot of
person power into like gravitational
wave background detection and then
after we detect the gravitational wave
background it'll really be a background
in fact it's a bit of a misnomer right
now it's the foreground signal it's
it's what we're looking for and
hopefully one day it'll be a background
signal that we're trying to subtract
right and then we can look for things
like anisotropy in the gravitational
wave background and
um this will look a lot like one of the
cmb maps maybe you even have one of
those beach balls
in your office brian i do um
and then we can find individual
supermassive black hole binary systems
or
when we can eventually constrain how
that amplitude
evolves as a function of gravitational
wave frequency then maybe we can say
you know it's 90 supermassive black
holes and 10
cosmic strings or maybe it's
you know 80 primordial because
that's just the way the universe is and
the rest of it is from like this puny
population of super massive black
holes but really you know it's it's all
like porosis
very good uh lindsay forbes is a good
friend of the show
just says dr kiara you explained this
complicated stuff so well
and i love the way you use your hands to
explain the signals thumbs up so that's
a tip
to uh folks to uh to yeah she's i don't
know she might be part italian or you
might be jewish
i don't know we use our fingers and
hands a lot in at least in my culture
uh kiara thank you so much there's one
from ernesto uh i have to take it he's a
he's a good friend of the show as well
on youtube is there a noisy or random
nature to the gravitational wave
background pattern
or does it manifest uh some regularities
how what a great question so the
gravitational wave background itself is
uh stochastic or at least we believe it
to be stochastic which means random
right and so this happens because
supermassive black holes
over their cosmic merger history they
evolve really slowly at these very low
frequencies and so there's a pileup of
sources
they're all in this one to 100 nanohertz
range where we have
our experiment at the same time and then
eventually
they take off and merge but for example
if you have
two billion solar mass black holes that
are merging and they're equal mass
let's say they are about 25 million
years from merging at 1 nanohertz
right 25 million years to get across the
pulsar timing array band now compare
that to ligo where their sources are in
their band for
a fraction of a second 25 million years
so you can get
a lot of supermassive black holes at low
frequencies
over 25 million years and that's what
creates this background
now even though it's a stochastic signal
it has things like an amplitude and this
spectral dependence
and that means that we can you know
define some global properties
of the background even though we can't
resolve individual sources we know
things about the ensemble of
supermassive black holes that we're
looking at so this amplitude this
frequency dependence
for example very good okay
miguel do you have a quick question on
clubhouse otherwise i will finish up
or maybe rockwell if you have a question
for kiara i'm inviting you guys up
uh and azada if you would like to ask a
question i'll invite you up
so this clubhouse we gotta get kiara on
clubhouse because as michael is saying
on youtube definitely have her back this
is a great mind bending this is great
mind bending stuff
she is bending my mind more than
gravitational waves
bends space time wow michael that's
about one part in 10 to the 15
so it's not actually a big compliment
you just insulted her michael
that's one part in a million billion
michael just to let you know
try harder michael uh let's see miguel
you're up there
uh you got a quick question for kiara
before i ask the final question to her
go ahead miguel she is listening
just wanted to know what is your most
cherished piece of memorabilia from your
career
oh
can i go get it it's in the fireplace
man
go get it all right she is uh for those
of you not watching on youtube
take the opportunity go to youtube yeah
i see you there thanks my brother so
here is back here she is and memorabilia
go to youtube dr bryan keating if you
want to see it live
oh my gosh what is that yeah so
the first year of my phd i worked on
experimental gravity i was looking for
compactified extra dimensions predicted
by string theory
and this is at the university of
birmingham and
i'm clearly a theorist but when i got to
birmingham
my the experiment that i was supposed to
use to look for compactified extra
dimensions was not built
so my then supervisor told me to design
um an interferometer that could make
nanometer surface corrugation
measurements so we could make sure we
weren't detecting the casimir force that
we were detecting
torques from extra dimensions so
as a good theorist i was terrified and
then
decided to get to work so i built and
designed a mock zender interferometer
that could do nanometer surface
corrugation measurements
and part of that was doing a machine
class where i machined
uh all of the components for my
interferometer and this is
uh one of the components that i made so
i
i
i made absolutely everything here the
screws the the threading inside
i used a lathe to machine all of the
aluminum you can
this um holds a laser diode
right here and that you can screw into
place with this screw
there's a lens here to focus your beam
uh and then you can take off the front
to put in a new lens
and then this you know attached to the
top of my
of my optical tabletop experiment
and i ate lots of thor snacks
while i thor lab snacks those of us who
build things know exactly what kiara is
talking about
that i think that's the most cherished
thing that i have in terms like a
physical thing
you know i have a rule against inviting
theorists into my lab but now i
i know i will be safe to invite you into
the laboratory i actually had sir roger
penrose in the lab last year
and you know we're still going to break
something we're still cleaning up the
debris yeah
this is pre-nobel prize so afterwards
now we can't even fit his ego in though
i'm just kidding he's like oh
we're not all right so we've got all
these compliments they want to have a
show just with you for another hour
uh we were gonna we're gonna make that
happen kiara just reassured me in
humanity
gave me hope that there are intelligent
hard-working people trying to understand
the secrets
of the underlying universe that's really
beautiful ibrahim
thank you so much uh lindsay says you
got to get it back
javier says exp extraordinary talk for
the non-specialist thanks i want to ask
you one last question if you are willing
in the remaining minute that we're over
i want to ask you kiara a question i
asked all my guests from nobel prize
winners to billionaires
to olympic athletes the astronauts i had
an astronaut
on recently i'm going to ask you this
question and i apologize for not
alerting you ahead of time but maybe you
watched
some of the video homework assignments i
sent you i asked all my i didn't get to
the end of them
i wish i did now all right now you've
got your homework set up
um i want to ask you uh the title of
this podcast is into the impossible
and it derives its name from uh from sir
arthur c clarke who had all these
famous aphorisms one of which is any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic another
one is
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert
and the third one kind of relates to
advice i would i
want to hear your advice to your former
self and it says it goes as follows the
only way
of determining what is possible is to
venture beyond the limits of the
possible
into the impossible that's the name of
this podcast i want to ask you as a
younger person
you know maybe 15 years ago 10 15 10 or
15 years ago
what advice would you give to a younger
version of kiara to help her have the
courage to go into the impossible
oh my goodness uh what would i tell
myself
i would uh tell myself to hang in there
that nobody has all the answers and
everyone is struggling just as much as
me
and that um you know even people who you
think have it all together
and that are brilliant they're just
people
um there are some people who are more
famous than other people
there are some people who are smarter
than other people some people who are
kinder than other people
um but no one is uh better
than you and everyone struggles
and everyone you know has has a whole
history of things that you don't know
anything about that's affecting them
every single day so i would tell myself
to
hang in there and do your best and
you can always be proud of things even
if it doesn't work out right like
like my tabletop moxender
i didn't complete the experiment i
started working on gravitational waves
instead
and it's going pretty good the world is
richer for that
uh and the universe as well kiara i want
to thank you so much dr
professor kiara mingarelli the
university of connecticut
stores go huskies my mom's alma mater
and also
of the flatiron institute the compete
center for computational astrophysics
where
[Laughter]
we all are huge fans obviously we got to
have you back maybe in a few months
you'll
uh grace us again with your with your
presence and i want to thank you so much
from the bottom of my heart for a goat
for going into the impossible with my
audience
oh thank you so much for having me i'd
be happy to come back
okay bye kiara bye everybody at
clubhouse we'll do another one later on
this week maybe with kamal
rav account we're trying to get him on
bye guys take care bye kiara